ask him to ask two questions I want to know. So what do you do? How often do you check MRD?
And what do you do if the MRD is going up? What was the second question?
If MRD is rising. So how do you manage that in the context of all the trials you're going to show us?
So I'm doing MRD testing much more than I expected to be. And it is a very patient driven thing,
to be honest. Patients are very aware of what MRD means, and they want to know if they've
achieved MRD negativity. So I kind of can't believe how often we're checking MRD negativity.
But as we'll talk about, not necessarily outside of studies using it for
therapy decisions right now. That's my own practice. All right. The second question you
asked, by the way, I'm just glossing over because that is a very, very difficult question.
That's why I asked it.
If it's a large slippage, what I usually am doing is I'm bracing patients for the need to switch
therapy soon, but I'm not necessarily switching right then. I realize that there are colleagues
here probably on this stage who are initiating therapy when that happens. I know I can name
several, but...
I guess we'll talk about that in the discussion. So thank you.
Can you come back for that? I'm not sure. But anyway, all right. So we're going to talk about
MRD guided therapy for newly diagnosed multiple myeloma. This is a very hard topic. And I'm not
going to try... I'm not going to give a lot of specific examples of studies where we did it.
I'm not going to try and explain how the field's been shaped by trials that do this. I want to
talk about the concept of using it and the pros and cons of using it. Let's start with why it's
important. Why MRD matters. We obviously know this. We know that MRD refines prognosis beyond
the usual clinical parameters that we measure, CR and stringent CR. We know that achieving MRD
negativity correlates with better PFS and overall survival. And it's increasingly being used as a
surrogate endpoint in newly diagnosed myeloma trials for this reason. This is actually a
great example of why MRD is so important. And I think it's a great example of why MRD is so important.
And I think it's a great example of why MRD is so important. And I think it's a great example of why
complete response rates and complete response rates are so high and survival is so long and
progression-free survival is so long. We need an earlier marker to keep the field moving forward
as we refine regimens, right? So this is practical, right? But this is not the same thing as using it
to make treatment decisions. This is a surrogate endpoint for the outcomes that we care about down
the road. We just know they're going to happen years later, right?
I covered this point. We know that this is actually true. This has been shown in transplant
eligible and ineligible patients, newly diagnosed and in relapsed patients. And we also know that
there may be some patient subsets where achieving MRD negativity isn't quite as predictive of
outcome or doesn't overcome certain kinds of risk. The master study, which we've heard about already,
is an example of an MRD-driven trial where when patients achieve what they called MRD-sure,
which is basically sustained MRD negativity, they enter a treatment-free observation period.
And what we saw was that patients who had two or more high-risk cytogenetic features
basically did more poorly using the strategy. But it may not, you know, it may not be a
function of having stopped therapy because we also know that in the Griffin study, you have
very, very similar curves. So again, when you don't have a randomized decision around that MRD
check, there are limitations to what you can learn. I'm going to come back to this point.
So currently, we know that it's prognostically significant. We talked about it as an eligible
factor for clinical trials or a surrogate endpoint in clinical trials. And there are selected
situations where based on some of the data that's emerged that I personally use it. So the main,
I think the most common scenario is the patient who's on maintenance therapy and sort of suffering
from years of grade one toxicity that doesn't really necessarily result in an absolute stop
to therapy, but they just aren't having the quality of life they want. And so they're really
wanting to get off maintenance therapy. And you're trying to just get as much data as you can
about, you know, is it rational? Is it safe to do? And knowing that a patient is MRD negative does
provide maybe some reassurance. And so sometimes I use it that way in a standard risk patient off
of a study, but that's one of the few examples. The key question is, you know, outside of those
kinds of isolated scenarios,
should we be using it to guide management? And so a few things before I sort of like
render an opinion about that is first, we should be thinking about it as came up earlier as how
deep is the response? MRD measurements are really how deep have we suppressed disease? Not is it a
yes, no. We've already learned that there's differences, you know, based on your threshold
in terms of prognostically what it means to achieve MRD negativity and 10 to the minus fifth
is currently proposed as meaningful for making
treatment decisions if we're going to study that question. Some people, some studies do use 10 to
the minus sixth. It's a marrow sampling test right, right now, but there will be blood based MRD
testing in the future, hopefully. And as we heard in the just the last talk, the biology of
extramedullary disease is different. And it's important to remember when we're using MRD testing
to declare somebody, you know, negative, that imaging really doesn't
need to be part of the equation in these patients. So I'm going to just kind of talk about a couple
of different basic strategies. One is MRD guided therapy escalation, right? So for example,
a patient who's MRD positive status post some kind of abduction therapy, we know they have
inferior outcomes. And so we do something in response to them continuing to be MRD positive.
We either add consolidation, we switch therapy, we do something like that. This is an example of a
with Christine Yee at the University of Michigan, where patients started with DRD and then escalated
to DVRD if they remained MRD positive, and then escalated to the option of transplant if they
still remained MRD positive. Otherwise, if at some point they become negative, they go on to
maintenance therapy, right? That was the basic design of the study. And the idea is patients
loved this study, right? I'm only getting what I need. If I don't need more than a triplet, great.
The problem, theoretically, right, is that you are,
potentially selecting for resistant clones before you move in with the full, most intensive,
most effective regimen, right? So you might be selecting for resistant disease. So this strategy
too is MRD guided de-escalation, right? So reducing therapeutic intensity or discontinuing therapy if
a patient becomes MRD negative, biologically a bit more rational. It's actually a refinement of the
strategy that we already use to treat patients, right? Maintenance therapy, right, is a de-escalation.
We're using an endpoint, a more powerful endpoint, to decide who gets de-escalation. And numerous
studies, Master was one. We did another study with Andrei Jakubovic, ELO-KRD, with very, very good
outcomes. Basically, if patients achieved sustained MRD negativity with ELO-KRD, then they went to an
ELO-RD maintenance therapy, and we got rid of the carfilzomib and an MRD-driven decision.
So building it into trials, I just want to, I'm going to kind of leave
you with just a couple of points. One, most of the data that we actually have looks at it sort
of as a fork in the road. You know, if patients remain positive, we do this, and if patients
become negative, we do that. That's not really probably best approach. That's not what we learn
the most from. This is the kind of thing that we learn the most from, where a certain MRD status
is achieved, and then you compare two different strategies based on the achievement of that
strategy. We have a certain MRD status, and then you compare two different strategies based on the
achievement of that strategy. We have the lead investigator of a very important study that's
going to answer the question about, you know, what do we do with MRD-negative patients and
maintenance therapy and the duration of maintenance, right? So super important trial,
and I'm going to just leave you with a couple of other examples of well-designed
key trials that use MRD to guide therapy. We've heard about the MIDAS trial, and, you know,
we've already learned things because there were randomizations, right? We've already learned that
transplant doesn't add an awful lot after you achieve MRD-negativity with ISA-KRD induction.
We've also learned that double transplant doesn't do more than a single transplant in terms of
deepening response if patients are still MRD-positive after induction therapy. But for
Sergio, we did learn that transplant does sometimes take these MRD-positive patients
and push them all the way to negative using a 10 to the minus 6 threshold when you add transplant.
And so I'm going to leave that and just food for thought for future clubs.